[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kale West and uh today this is another
part of my youth so you had a he-man
Thundercats a transformers now this is a
part of my youth that was very near and
dear to me to be honest with you I give
you sideshows the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles that's the team right there you
see them all four turtles and all that
glory give you a quick story when I was
a 16 years old I was working at a comic
book store and you know it was a comic
store a local comic book store and he
couldn't pay cash so what he would do
was he would give comic books he would
pay me in comic books
so I remember the truck coming in I
remember we unboxing and he said you
know you know this is the books this
week and I think DC were had a lull and
Marvel had a low so I said um what's
this right here and he was like all this
you know some new line Easterlin Lenox
these men on Lenox
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
and I said well I'll take two of these
so I took to number one right and it was
such a good read so automatically I just
you know kept going kept reading and my
fandom group now Nickelodeon got ahold
of them and you know Nickelodeon did
what they did to him but initially then
the Ninja Turtles were ruthless group of
teenagers and the foot soldiers weren't
robots or mute annoyed or whatever they
were they were ninjas assassins and very
good stuff so today what we're gonna do
is this is the first time I'm bringing
you a video with multiple statues so
this video is going to give you a
breakdown of each statue right so I'm
gonna go and we're gonna talk about the
differences between each statue and what
makes them stand out and what I feel is
you know the best attributes and
probably pick up the best of the four
you know and give you a synopsis on that
so let's dig right into it first up it's
Michelangelo
now this by no means pixel who I like
the most is just random draw
so Michelangelo Michelangelo is the none
chuckin ninja turtle
and his identity is basically of the
Nunchuk if you look at each turtle their
personality is basically what they
weapons are so where the nunchucks is
fast bashing furious it looks like it's
out of control but it's in like a
control state and it's whimsical it's
young it's fun
that's Michelangelo in a nutshell that's
his fighting style his fighting style is
fun its brash it's a little bit over the
top it's a controlled chaos to be honest
with you
so this statute his statue is an
exclusive all the statues here are
exclusive and it comes with its tools to
switch out portraits the switch out
portraits arm the bandanas now all the
turtles had a red bandana in the books
and to when Nickelodeon got ahold of one
they switched it that they had to have
different colors so the colors
indicating which Ninja Turtle you were
looking at all which one was in a
particular scene said if we couldn't see
their weapons because only the weapons
could tell you exactly you know who was
who so if you look at the level of
detail on the statute the statue is
impeccably done with the nunchucks in
and all proper angles as he's like
spinning and he's standing on top of the
metal piping with the hoos that's down
there cuz then the suit was the detail
on his shell is beautiful the textures
on his chest piece his legs his mouth
his eyes the fact that they made sure
because the originals didn't have any
pupils the fact that they made sure that
they didn't have any Cupid really stands
out for me and I think Michelangelo is
one of the top ones when it comes to me
these statues here so get on to the next
Donatello
Donatello is just like his bo staff very
disciplined very sure of herself
he's a introvert that keeps people at
arm's length and he feels more
comfortable with his Zen self the tech
side of things then with actual humans
so that's where you would see the
organic mix of the bo staff and the
power in the length and a distance in
which the bo staff will keep you so this
is an exclusive and like I stated before
the exclusive is the portrait the
portrait comes with the purple headband
Anna and it comes with the red bandanna
the red bandanna like I said previously
has everything to do with how they were
originally visioned and they all had a
unified front going forward the way his
stance is and his arm is out and the bo
staff is behind his body shows you a lot
of them he's actually the tallest one in
height when it comes to the statues
because he's on like a half pipe with
the sewer dripping down the front of it
and he's towers above so he can see over
the group which actually you know
depicts the character because you know
his thing is range in distance so of
course his range and his distance would
the representative in the statue which
is the height the range which is the
length in a distance it was his the
death of this statute it's this is this
is going to be a hard one to pick which
one that you might feel as your best
Leonardo the so-called leader of the
bunch I never really considered Leonardo
the leader but Leonardo has to be the
leader because when we think of ninja
weapons when you think of Asian weapons
you know the Orient we think as the
katana is above all right the katana is
precise sharp deliberate purposeful the
katana is Leonardo
in a nutshell leonardo is purposeful
he's sharp he's decisive straight to the
point
cuts
[Music]
and he's a master of his craft so that
way you would see that this character
would be the leader of the group because
he will galvanize the group and he will
make deliberate smart decisions and he
would be the steel that keeps them
together and speaking of still the
swords on this is made out of real metal
on this statue
very nice detail the green pops of his
skin is an exclusive comes with two
portraits and again the second portrait
is the red bandanna and the first
portrait is the blue bandanna so that
way you know has a swap-out
and the faces are different so then you
have different facial expressions when
it comes with but he's the lowest one
he's crouching down like he's in
position to strike
and he's already thought out his plan
and you have seconds to live the statute
again is in the soybeans on the pipe he
has the knee down and he has the blades
out and that curved and then made out of
metal and I think this statue is one of
the most vibrant ones because I've
noticed that Michelangelo and Donatello
they their skin tone is a little bit the
same and Raphael and Leonardo skin tone
is the same maybe we have our two sets
of twins which would be absolutely nuts
that's another aspect of the statues and
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles that I
didn't even conceive in my head but
that's Leonardo aka the leader of the
Turtles now we have last but not least
aha Raphael the hothead the muscle the
Brawn behind the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles as you can see he is my favorite
Ninja Turtle
full disclosure
after reading the books he reminded me
of the character like a Wolverine type
of character and I felt that you know he
would be he's the catalyst to make this
go he he's gonna be it
so sighs sighs are the weapons that he
used sighs are they were made to combat
katanas so they would trap the katana in
between the outside stretched sink the
katana with the tum in here it would
catch it this way and we'll be able to
break it off break it and hit them with
the butt of the side jab them with the
pointy end of the side and the side was
able to capture weapons and also do
damage all the way through so this is
where you get Raphael Raphael is a
hothead a risk-taker he's the wild card
in the bunch he's the one that uh
is definitely gonna be the first one in
it'll last one out when it comes to a
battle so you can tell that his style
and Leonardo's will always clash because
the katana is made to the size are made
to fight the katana and break the katana
so it takes a lot of discipline to like
beat that back so Raphael is a handful
handful when it comes to the group not a
statute the statute he's the biggest one
the heaviest one out of all Lorne
he's an exclusive
is exclusive is he comes with Casey
Jones that's right the hockey puck the
hockey mask hockey puck slapping hockey
stick
carrying baseball bat welding vigilante
from the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles so
his comes with the Casey Jones mask and
he doesn't have a switch out poetry so I
think the fact that he doesn't have a
switch out portrait they love to do more
detail on this character because they
saw an entity X so he's a little bit
bigger he has you know a lot more detail
when it comes to his base when you look
at the piping the piping looks like real
nice piping and the boos looks like you
know real like sewer ooze so if you want
me to pick who's the best I'm gonna
probably go a Raphael I was gonna
probably go a Raphael anyway because
Raphael is he's demanding me so let's
get into this team Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles the team what more can I say
they fight as a as a discipline unit
Master Splinter has been fighting as the
last ninjas so you have a bowl staff
that you keep that distance you had
nunchucks that can actually cut distance
and keep you in close and beat you close
then you have the katana which the blade
that can cut through almost anything if
swung properly would proper force and
proper discipline and you have the
katana the size that is actually made to
chop weapons and break weapons and break
bones so this unit
these Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles that
has inhabited our lives that Nickelodeon
has taken in
from what they initially was to
something greater than sum of all their
parts Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles I am
so proud to bring this to you but this
is the part of the video where I'm gonna
ask you to like follow and subscribe
and also go to loads of gaminguys net
where you can get all the latest
information all the fun opinion pieces
all the latest reviews and you get their
last word with all Cognito and advantage
and don't forget to watch hardcore
reviews with addict I mean I can't
believe half the stuff that he does to
be honest with you it's utterly
incredible you can also see older
episodes of Kos you can see that he-man
and Thundercats that vulture on all my
youth all in one package and also you
can get combat talk with the king but I
talk about MMA boxing and other you know
forms of martial arts there that goes on
in the world of combat sports so don't
forget to hit that joint button hit that
joint button join up on the room join me
on my journey so you can see these
videos and i'ma stop posting flower
joint members a little exclusive videos
I got an inception video that I've been
working off for a minute so
see you next week hey stick around so
you can see these Turtles in all their
glory without me talking then you can
get a chance to see them up close and
see more detail with video and pictures
and listening to some nice music
remember always state collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]